What major issue is Scalability. If you've got an interesting application,
that's distributed across the internet, it might grow. That is, it might,
have more users over time. Or it might have, a greater load,
due to the individual users. In either case,
you want to be able to grow the application. And the question then is,
how easy is it to grow? This is sometimes called scaling. That is,
how easy is it to scale your application? Scaling typically takes the form of
adding new hardware. And the question then becomes, to what extent will
adding new machines change your system architecture, or its components? Ideally,
we'd like to grow transparently. What transparency means is, whether or
not a particular aspect of a systems architecture is visible externally,
that is, to the, the other machines. If it's invisible, of course, you can
scale as much as you want, and the rest of the system would not be concerned.